Hi, I'm Apolonia
Gardner, and I'm
a junior in computer science,
biology and neuroscience.
And today I'm going to
tell you about my project
on the striatum.
So there are three
things you need to know.
The striatum is
a brain structure
linked to Huntington's disease.
It contains two types of cells,
striosomes and matrix cells.
And is directly involved in
cost benefit decision making.
And so the goals
of my project are
to characterize the
roles of these two cell
types in decision
making and also
to run wild type and
Huntington's disease mice
through these behavioral
studies to figure out
if there's an underlying
circuitry change
in Huntington's mice.
And so I'll first talk about
my calcium imaging results.
So calcium imaging,
in general, is a way
that we can see cells
lighting up in the brain
and correlate that
activity with behavior.
And so here I'm showing you four
different types of T-maze tasks
that we run our mice in.
And each of them
are characterized
by different levels of costs
and rewards on either side.
The rewards being different
levels of chocolate milk.
And costs being different
intensities of light.
And below I'm showing you heat
map plots of neural activity
for striosomes
and matrix neurons
in the four task types, where
red represents high activity
and blue represents
low activity.
And so for example,
striosomes in the benefit,
benefit tasks seem to
be relatively active
regardless of whether the mouse
goes towards the pure chocolate
milk side or the mixture.
Whereas, in the cost,
cost, striosomes
seem to be relatively
active when
the mouse goes towards the high
cost side, but not the low cost
side.
Behaviorally we see
a striking change
between Huntington's
and wild type mice.
So Huntington's
disease mice seem
to be relatively repetitive
and fixed in their behavior.
So given their choice
on a previous trial,
they tend to make
that same choice
on like the next
trial, two trials
after, three trials
after, four trials after.
Versus, wild type mice, which
their choices are largely
unaffected by the history.
And lastly, we use
electrophysiology
to kind of visualize
the spike wave forms
that we're recording over here.
So here I'm showing you two
different classes of neurons
in the striatum.
And they have different
spike wave forms.
This one goes up and then down.
This one goes down and then up.
So we already know that
there are different types
of neurons in the striatum.
And that these belong
to different groups.
And then based on the
time between spikes,
this neuron has very
small ties between spikes.
So it fires really
fast and doesn't stop.
This one has more variable
time between spikes.
So it doesn't fire as reliably.
And so based on
these properties,
you can classify neurons
into different types.
And so for future
directions, we're
going to run more mice
through this pipeline
to kind of resolve some of
these behavioral neural activity
trends better to see if we can
elucidate Huntington's disease.